[Music]
foreign
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
a warning that the state pension age may
have to rise to 70 by 2050 due to the
pressure on public finances
defense contractor Babcock facing a hit
of up to 100 million pounds over its
contract to deliver frigates to the
Royal Navy
Tesla to cut prices to boost demand
that's a new report suggests interest in
electric cars may be waning
plus calls to establish a national
platform to bridge the digital skills
Gap
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
heart of the city now the state pension
age may have to be raised by the
government to 70 by 2050 due to pressure
on the public finances that's the
warning today from The Institute for
fiscal studies which also points out
that 9 in 10 workers are saving less
than is needed for a decent standard of
living in retirement the ifs is now
launching a two-year review into
possible pensions reform overseen by
Aleister darling the former labor
Chancellor and David gork the former
conservative Secretary of State for work
and pensions for joining me now is Carl
Emerson he's the deputy director of the
ifs Carl good to see you this morning I
mean we should State at the outset the
situation is very very healthy but it's
this demise of so-called final salary
pensions coming down the line that is
going to cause problems
you certainly the situation for current
pensioners at least on any good their
incomes are holding up very well
relative to the working age population
and in terms of poverty rates um the
system's working well in the sense that
pensions are less likely to be in
poverty than the working age population
so that's not the motivation for our
review what we're worried about is
actually those successes for today's
pensioners might be making us a bit
complacent about what the future might
hold and we're really worried about the
fact that yes we've got lots more
private sector employees into pensions
that's a great success but most of them
are not saving very much we've also got
increasing numbers of people in
self-employment and yet the numbers are
self-employed who are engaging with a
pension has declined very dramatically
over the last 25 years so concerns that
perhaps many private sector workers
employees or self-employed just aren't
doing enough to give them the retirement
they might expect
why is it that self-employed people in
particular are not saving as much
it is a little
Street um we've seen a decline in the
engagement in pensions amongst the
self-employed right the way through
since about the mid-1990s
um it's a remarkable change over that
period we've now got fewer than one in
five self-employed people saving in a
pension and that wouldn't matter if for
example they were just self-employed for
a short period of time and perhaps they
were saving when they were employee but
the drop in pension engagement amongst
the self-employed is actually biggest
amongst those who are long-term
self-employed so that really is cause
for a concern and even though
self-employed who are saving in a
pension often put in relatively small
amounts obviously they don't get an
employer contribution and often those
amounts stay fixed in cash terms for
very long periods of time so we're
worried about their saving patterns too
and in terms of those who are in private
sector employment I mean you you make
clear that 30 to 40 year olds are not
really saving enough right now would it
help if the employer contribution was
was raised by on a mandatory basis
there's going to be various things that
we'll look at should we be
um defaulting people in at higher
contributions either from themselves or
from their employers is clearly one
thing that we should consider that would
be building on the success of automatic
enrollment where the government has
managed um over the last decade or so to
move to a situation where fewer than
half of private sector workers are in a
pension the one where amongst employees
it's almost 90 so those are certainly
options on the table for our review
saving more perhaps retiring later
perhaps or indeed at least accepting
that the living standards in retirement
perhaps won't keep Pace with what
current pension is on average are
enjoying now what about the the state
pension age uh clearly uh it's going to
put more pressure on the public finances
I mean the current Triple Rock Has
Lifted people out of poverty what
outline from if you're a police car what
the impact would be on the public
finances if the current Arrangements
remain in place and all other things
remain equal
one option to help people with their
retirement saving is of course to make
the state pension more generous but that
does look difficult in a world where on
the government's projections over the
next 50 years
um we'll be spending the equivalent of
100 billion a year more on the state
pension because of the triple lock
because of an aging population because
of people living longer at older ages
and that comes on top of an increasing
bill for the NHS and social care so you
know the state perhaps could do more but
that's already looking difficult given
those projections so I think we do need
to look at solutions that involve
individuals or employers
um doing more we also have to look at
the risks that people are bearing as
well
what about public sector pensions
they're obviously incredibly generous
compared with most private sector
pensions is that going to fall under
your review as well you're going to look
at that
it's not going to form part of our
review particularly for the reason you
just say actually public sector pensions
don't look like they're causing any
problems in terms of the adequacy of
those workers pensions once they get to
retirement there are issues there
clearly about whether they're the best
use of taxpayer money to get and retain
the public sector workers we want
clearly at the moment you might wonder
whether for example higher pay and
perhaps less generous pensions would be
a better deal for all but we're going to
be focused on where we think that the
pension system isn't delivering decent
standards of living or risk of not
delivering a decent stand of living in
retirement so public sector pensions
don't look like they're causing that
kind of problem and of course that helps
quite a few private sector workers too
because they may well be married to
somebody who works in the public sector
all right I've got to leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and the Outsourcing and defense
contractor babcockhorn this morning that
it may face a one-off hit of between 50
to 100 million pounds related to its
contract to deliver five type 32
frigates to the Royal Navy Babcock said
that costs on the project have been
pushed up due to inflation and that had
been talking to the ministry of Defense
as to who was responsible for the
additional costs under the contract it
said it had been unable to reach an
agreement with the mod and that as a
result a dispute resolution process had
begun which could lead to an arbitration
Babcock warned that with that recovery
of the additional costs the contract
would be loss making and that a one-off
provision would be required to cover the
duration of the contract Babcock Shares
are currently off two and a quarter
percent
one disco the Under Fire software
company said this morning it had been
told by the financial conduct Authority
that it is under investigation by the
regulator the Sheffield based company
said the investigation related to
certain regulatory announcements it had
released between the beginning of last
year to 9th of March this year that may
have materially misstated its financial
position well the news comes two weeks
after one disco's chief executive and
Chief Financial Officer stepped down
after the company discovered accounting
irregularities
and the Bookseller and stationary
retailer wh Smith has this morning
reported better than expected half-year
profits the company which has been
repositioning itself from its
Traditional High Street retailer
operations towards outlets at Railway
stations and airports reported a pre-tax
profit of 45 million pounds for the six
months to the end of February that was
up from 19 18 million pounds in the same
period a year earlier with Carl Carling
the chief executive hailed a return to
air travel and commuting for the
Improvement he said that by the end of
The Current financial year wh Smith's
travel division would account for more
than 70 percent of sales and around 80
percent of profits
some breaking news for you now and the
UK has slipped down the global rankings
of countries involved in the export of
goods and services figures published in
the last half hour by the department for
international trade revealed that the UK
is now seventh globally for goods and
services exports down from fifth in
2020. the UK's ranking and imports of
goods and services remained unchanged at
six well the value of UK total trade in
the 12 months to the end of January came
in at 1.7 trillion pounds that was up
26.4 percent on the previous 12 months
well with me now is Simon French he's
managing director and head of research
at pamel Gordon Simon good to see you
this morning
um what struck me is that the terms of
trade for non-eu countries is less
favorable to the uh UK than uh it is
with EU countries the the trade deficit
appears bigger yes and this is a feature
of the type of things that the UK has
been forced over the last 12 months to
import particularly uh natural resources
particularly natural gas and then that
is dominating the trade picture actually
not just in the UK around the world of
course that will start to go into
reverse so looking ahead as we always
must with this data we'll start to see
those terms of trade rather improving I
suspect given where wholesale gas prices
we have to say the price of natural gas
although very uncomfortable for lots of
businesses and households has sent a
signal to suppliers around the world in
terms of trade to up capacity up their
shippings of liquefied national gas
helping getting prices down it's the
function of prices that's a very healthy
thing in capitalist markets absolutely I
mean to what extent are these figures
distorted by gold in ports and exports I
mean it's something that constantly
messes with the trade figures it is and
uh one of your colleague Ed Conway
writes extensively about this doesn't he
and the the Distortion of uh of
non-monetary gold particularly the UK
which is a big uh custodian of gold and
therefore cross-border flows does
disrupt the headline trade figures when
you strip that out you do see a problem
and this ranking you mentioned in your
introduction is symptomatic of this the
UK is running a persistent trade deficit
even when the Sterling index is down at
levels or subdued levels are too decade
low and against the dollar briefly at a
four decade low doesn't seem to really
be helping the structural trade balance
when you strip out those disruptive
forces of which non-monetary gold is one
of them yeah which of course brings us
on to the inflation data which we we had
yesterday I mean the UK has the highest
rate of inflation in in Europe now it's
obviously particularly I mean the UK has
always had a problem with sticky
inflation is that down to the fact that
we we import so much more than we export
trade deficit is clearly part of this
story and the fact that uh food is such
a crucial component part of this going
up 19 almost twice the rate of headline
inflation the fact that we import a
large part of our our food base is part
of that and the weakness of Sterling
just amplifies that effect the problem
of course here is when you look and you
try and Benchmark Global Food price
inflation actually even areas that have
quite a considerable export volumes have
faced quote considerable food inflation
as well that fertilizer cost a very
intensive energy intensive part the
production process feeds through with a
lag and although those prices have come
down crop Cycles are not done in the
matter of days weeks Contracting is done
over multiple years so although the
headline input price that will drive
food is coming down consumers aren't
seeing this at the moment and they will
be frustrated by that it's become going
to become intensely political in the U K
and across the world in the coming
months of our profiteering well is it
well it's a very good point you raise
that because I'm in the ons in its
statement yesterday said that while
wholesale food prices were coming down
supermarkets weren't yet passing that on
I mean that's all the ons dipping its
toe in political Waters there it is
having the ons the statistic
statisticians are dipping their toe into
this central banks of their turn to this
but this is the purview of the uh
competition and markets Authority I
think they are the people who need to be
hearing from because otherwise you have
people who really don't have a role they
own us to measure central banks to
manage inflation but in terms of you
think that the bargaining process
between suppliers and consumers is is
inappropriate not fit for purpose the
CMA get involved I think there are too
many commentators on the pitch if I dare
say so we completely agree I mean but
the CMA has looked at grocery retail in
this country several times over the last
couple of decades they've never
concluded that there was an issue with
competition I mean Tesco Sainsbury's all
of them their margins are less than five
percent in most cases I mean that
doesn't look like a market in which uh
that they're hot you know they're
hogging profits and uh yeah yeah I mean
Curry you're correct you'll be new and
I've been in the market long enough to
see these a successional reviews they're
more a decade or so ago most of these
reviews but each and every one of them
and many people teed up the CMA and
their predecessors to do the emergency
uh Monopoly mergers uh authority to look
at this never found a case of
profiteering now you can argue that the
balance of consumers versus suppliers is
not for purpose but that is a political
instruction given to the CMA in their
terms of reference it's never found that
supermarkets have been profiteered it's
part of the UK economy which you would
say is intensely uh competitive and
that's what you want in capital markets
you want competition it's not about free
markets it's about competitive markets
and that's where the CMA have to uh
State what they want and whether they're
seeing behaviors because of the flux of
the pandemic the because the Flux Of The
the war because the flux of brexit
whether that has changed the dynamic
would become very used to particularly
in the supermarket sector over the last
20 years before I let you go just one
the more thought on the trade numbers I
mean the UK actually Rose in the
rankings of foreign direct investment in
the period that was being measured
second in the world now I mean that's is
that down to all these takeovers of UK
companies that people are getting so
agitated about yes and it is part of the
uh bright spot actually in financial
services is deal making in terms of
inward investment into mergers looking
particularly at public companies which
are priced at a considerable discount to
their Global peers if Public Market
investors are not prepared to Value
those appropriately we are seeing both
International capital and private
domestic Capital saying well public
markets in the UK are not going to do it
will come along and value that
appropriately accordingly so yes a
bright spot driven by currency driven by
that facility valuation discount all
right so I'm in good Oliver there great
to see you this morning thank you
a bit of breaking news to bring you and
that there have been fears that the
Animal Rights group animal Rising which
disrupted the Grand National last
Saturday had several plans for the
London Marathon this weekend in the last
few minutes the group has released a
statement denying that a spokesperson
said animal Rising has no intention to
disrupt the London Marathon this weekend
our action this year is intended to
shine the spotlight on other animals and
our relationship to them
some more business news for you now and
the Outsourcing group Capital warned
this morning that customer Supply or
colleague data may have been accessed by
hackers in a recent Cyber attack Capital
which collects the TV license fee on
behalf of the BBC and whose other
clients include Plymouth city council
Bayern Munich football club and
transport for London said there was some
evidence of limited data in exfiltation
from the small proportion of its service
affected it said the majority of its
Client Services were not impacted by the
incident and remained in operation it
has now restored virtually all client
services that were impacted
shares of jet 2 Rose by one percent this
morning after the tour operators said
Folia profits would be better than
expected jet2 said forward bookings for
the summer had remained encouraging to
date it's looking to sell 7.2 percent
more seats this summer than same period
last year with package holiday customers
representing just over three quarters of
total departing passengers or profits
for the year are now expected to come in
at between 387 and 392 million pounds
the UK government last month set
mandates for car manufacturers requiring
22 percent of the new cars they sell
next year to be zero emission that will
rise to 80 by 2030 but all of that
compares with the 16 of the market
currently accounted for by sales of
battery electric vehicles in the last
month those are the figures from the
Society of motor manufacturers and
Traders but according to the online
Automotive Marketplace Auto Trader
interest in electric cars may be raining
or joining me now is Erin Baker she's
editorial director at AutoTrader Aaron
good to see you this morning why do you
say interest is waning hi there yeah
well according to our figures on
AutoTrader interest in new electric cars
is down by 65 year on year it's a
slightly nuanced picture because
actually sales and interest in used EVS
remain pretty robust and are actually at
their strongest that they've been ever
at six percent market share but
certainly there's a huge drop-off in
interest for new electric cars and
you're measuring interest here by sort
of searches on the site exactly add
views yeah why do you think that is well
I think there are three key things the
first is cost of living crisis you know
it's affecting us all uh the average the
sticker price of an electric car is
still on average 37 more more than it is
for petrol or diesel so people that are
thinking about going electric and a lot
of consumers really do still want to
make that switch are looking at their
monthly household budgets and thinking
you know 37 more expensive
um there's also a lot of worries about
charging the charging network is it
there how much does it cost in
particular you know this this lack of
vat equality on domestic versus public
charging if you go to a public charger a
rapid charger in particular you're
paying that 20 bat and actually that can
make it quite Hefty yeah now overnight
Elon Musk at Tesla hinted at further
price Cuts over over the coming months
is that symptomatic of this weighing in
Decline it's not just a UK Factor it
must be Global if Tesla talking about
this it is global you know the car
brands are Global they operate across
different markets if we look at other
markets where they have successfully
bought EVS on board and their strong
consumer demand and take up you know
you're looking at a lot of government
incentives having to be there you look
at the UK where are our government
incentives you know we had a plug-in
Grant it's largely gone we had a
domestic charging Grant is largely gone
we don't have any information around
battery health for consumers and you
know people that want to look at a used
DB are thinking well hang on the car's
fine what about the battery I don't know
anything about that so you know where's
the standardization of messaging around
that are you saying then that the
government's Net Zero targets are
misguided unless they actually restore
some of these incentives I I think what
we see you know again if you look at use
consumer demand and interest is there
but so we could still be on track 2030
could still be a viable possibility but
it's going to take the government to
really I think step in look at things
like incentives around VAT on used cars
look at things like look at Norway they
do free charging free spaces free
parking all sorts of really interesting
Innovative interesting consumer
incentives to go electric and they don't
currently exist in the UK you mentioned
just now the differential between new
EVs and new Petra and diesel vehicles
was 37 I think you said what's it like
for for used cars used cars it's
narrowing it depends very much on the
model I mean actually if you if you
think about it for a lot of people out
there electric cars are a very new idea
but the likes of Renault Zoe Nissan Leaf
they've been with us for over a decade
now so actually there are some really
good used car Bargains out there and
there are a few models actually where
price parity exists I mean we thought
along with other people uh Auto Trader
we thought we were heading for Price
parity between electric and petrol and
Diesel around the middle of this decade
it's not happening it's not going to
happen without some help probably from
the government but you know there are a
few good Bargains to be had out there
now you mentioned just now the fact that
the government has been withdrawing
incentives of course in 2025 vehicle
excise duties going to be imposed on EVS
is that something that you think the
government perhaps ought to reconsider
definitely that's something for the
government to consider along with you
know benefit and kind for company car
users is going to shift upwards that's
been a really good incentive which
probably explains why two out of three
electric cars are company cars if we
want retail private purchases to get
behind electric we need some fiscal
incentive lives pretty soon all right
Aaron good to see you this morning thank
you
still to come morning King live we're
going to have a global look at how
Global markets are doing this Thursday
morning don't go away
[Music]
thank you
we'll start with breaking news
and we're going to interrupt that to
take you live to yes of course it has a
bearing on what's happening with
interest rates we're cutting out of that
to bring you some breaking news could
you tell us about the night that the
Russians were coming Russia is making
advances now listen it's quite a time as
you know Alex tell us what's happening
this is turning into a humanitarian
emergency
news never stops
we're breaking news for you neither do
we let's just come in to us here at Sky
News
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
week picked up momentum yesterday mid
growing speculation over the timing of
the U.S interest rate Rises about a
Brent crude this morning hit its lowest
level so far this month and is currently
changing hands at 81.71 cents a barrel
that is down nearly one and three
quarter percent on the session on the
equity market stocks in the Asia Pacific
region had a mixed session overnight not
really a great deal of action in any of
them truth be told Sydney Mumbai Hong
Kong and Shanghai were all more or less
unchanged the nicay meanwhile posted a
very modest game to make it nine games
in 10 sessions well in Europe markets
have largely been drifting lower this
morning there you can see the current
picture the ducks in Germany is off
nearly three quarters of one percent but
uh fairly uh modest declines across the
board mixed bag of company results
really I think uh behind that talking
points this morning include Renault the
French car maker is off some seven
percent in Paris that's despite the fact
that quarterly profits came in well
ahead of expectations we're here in
London the ftse 100 is also in negative
territory right now albeit not very much
it's only 11 points awful so broad-based
sell-off as ever on a Thursday at this
time of year there are a lot of stocks
going X dividend in other words they're
trading without the rights to the latest
payout among the batch this morning are
spirax Sarco the engineering company uh
if you own that one uh that's nothing to
worry about there that's just adjusted
because it's gone X div today offer one
and a half percent or so Melrose will uh
very interesting uh movement there uh
the price is uh all over the place
because uh it's uh demerged it's
Automotive Engineering arm dolls today
so a bit of volatility uh in that one
again I wouldn't uh Panic too much or or
indeed turn too many somersaults with
joy over that particular movement that
we're showing on the screen there a bit
all over the place that one today the
top Blue Chip gaino meanwhile is the
warehouse owner sea grow the shares up
some two and a half percent on a trading
update meanwhile the consumer held
Healthcare Group Haley on which was spun
out of GSK in July last year that's up
two percent on news at its full year
sales are going to come in at the top
end of expectations the shares have hit
an all-time high this morning as I say
per two percent or so outside the ftse
100 hawkside mining is off some 10
following a drop in annual profits but
the electronic components designer
Discovery is up one and a half percent
on news that its results will be better
than expected on the foreign exchange
markets well not very much to uh charge
about there really Sterling offered 10
to 1 against the US dollar under a
seventh of one percent right now against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
more or less unchanged against the
Greenback joining me this morning is
Anna stupnitzker she's Global macro
Economist at Fidelity International Anna
welcome to you uh obviously we're in the
thick of earnings season right now both
here in Europe and in the United States
what are the themes catching your eye
thus far
well for this um quota the real question
is is this the quarter when we're going
to see that earnings recession that has
been talked about and expected for a
while but obviously we know that
earnings seasons have been more
resilient and the economic data has been
more resilient so the question is is it
going to happen now and so far I would
say it is a mixed bag
um we have seen generally earnings
division before the season kicked off a
positive earnings division in Europe
more positivity more optimism in in
China and Asia a negative an intravision
in the U.S and so far it seems that the
bar for positive surprise particularly
in Europe is relatively High we have
seen mixed across a mix across sectors
so we're seeing a mix across regions so
a mixed bag so far
um and we think that this is going to be
a quarter where some of for that theme
about the earnings recession is going to
start coming through
I know in the UK I mean it strikes me
that a lot of businesses are surprising
to the upside I mean for example wh
Smith better than expected results today
jet 2 very positive for earnings update
have UK companies just been a little too
pessimistic in some of the guidance
they've been giving the market
uh yeah I I guess it's possible because
last year in particular we saw uh
collapse and consumer confidence
collapse and Cooperative confidence as
we're approaching the winter obviously
given the the energy shock and high
energy prices
the fiscal support helped
um and we started this year in much more
optimistic node given those worst fears
did not materialize last year so it's a
little bit of a payback from last year
but there is definitely but there is no
question that we are going towards slow
down and recession we expected both here
in the UK in Europe and in the US and
that should start coming through in the
data at some point but there has been
resilience so far
I know looking at your latest notes as a
house your underweight developed Market
Equity is an overweight emerging market
equities what's the uh thinking behind
that
yeah one reason is that the Emerging
Markets overall
um had been ahead in this tightening
cycle so the hike trades across the
board uh quite early and the the tithing
cycle is finished in many places perhaps
except for the the central list in
Europe
um and so in this respect inflation has
been slowing there and some central
banks are expected to start cutting
rates soon
um so uh it is just a different point in
the driving cycle that is one rationale
for this of course Emerging Markets are
not completely immune from what happens
in the developed world so if we are
going to see a recession if it's
relatively mild and this is what we
expect for now uh then the economist
Emerging Markets economists can still do
relatively well but if the recession is
deeper they're not going to be immune
what is helping of course is the China
rebound and the China rebound story is
one of the catalysts for a better
emerging market performance over the
next few months okay Anna we have to
leave it there great to see you this
morning appreciate it
still to come here only in King live
calls for a national digital skills
platform to help businesses handle the
rise of artificial intelligence don't go
away
[Music]
foreign
welcome back our sustainability is
becoming an increasingly pressing issue
in the tech space the focus now is on a
circular I.T economy and upcycling
Services something on which the it
multinational giant here at Packard
Enterprise hopes to capitalize it claims
to have given a second life to more than
8.2 million technology assets including
2.3 million servers 3.1 million PCS and
notebooks were joining now to talk about
this is Matt Harris he's hpe's UK
managing director Matt good to see you
this morning so what's happened to all
this stuff what have you done with it
good morning Ian uh glad you reference
sustainability as a core topic for a
number of businesses and if I think
about it and the contribution it makes
to Global uh emissions and carbon
emissions uh it represents about two to
three percent of total emissions and as
we become an increasingly digitized
world that has a scale to either grow
but also technology and technology
companies play an incredible role of
solving some of those challenges one of
the ways we we do that which you
referenced is in the asset upcycling and
renewing of old Tech to give them
another lease of life we do that here in
the UK in one of the largest technology
renewable centers in Europe just outside
of Glasgow wherever 95 of the products
we take in are given a second life or
recycled and less than half percent go
to landfill all right so where do they
go
um they can go to a number of markets
there might be customers who don't need
the latest Cutting Edge technology but
it suits their needs we also look at the
whole value chain of uh of how we Source
components when we go to the initial
manufacturing stages and then what we do
around the end of their life and they
can be put to any uh um industry from a
component perspective that they can't be
be reused right I mean you've also
committed to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions I mean the sector is notorious
for uh its activities on this front how
specifically you trying to manage those
lower
yeah we think about that in three ways
first of all if we think about our own
emissions we've taken stock of what we
can control ourselves with our own
operations
uh we have reduced by half our own
emissions uh that's within our Direct
Control by 50 we brought forward our
pledge to Net Zero by a decade last year
to 2040 but the biggest impact we can
make is actually through our customers
we actually have an obligation to our
customers to reduce their greenhouse gas
emissions we do that by providing more
efficient efficiency in the technologies
that we create for them to consume we do
that through our Cloud platform where we
are eliminating what we call over over
provisioning where customers have
bought more equipment that they aren't
using which is driving their
sustainability outcome and also through
the asset upcycling now the big thing
that we have with uh which is uh a a
great opportunity for all of all
organizations and governments is some of
the advancements around digital
Technologies and it's digital net
technologies that move at the scale and
the pace around solving big humanitarian
problems like climate change we do that
through super Computing we are invested
in Europe and America
allowing those uh those governments and
uh data scientists and
um economists to look at how we would
Advance things like renewable energy
sustainably and the great news that we
saw last month by the UK government was
the announcement of a 900 million pound
exascale computer we applaud that from
the UK government and we look forward to
speaking to the government about the
role we can play in that obviously uh
migrating services to the cloud though
implicit in that is greater energy usage
by by data centers and by servers is
that something you can really get a grip
on I think the real question here for
customers and for society is getting
down to a scientific Baseline looking at
all of our carbon emissions and
greenhouse gases
now offsetting that by moving where your
data center is or how you're consuming
technology is not an answer actually
it's about getting to a commonality of a
metric that you can measure if you can't
measure something you can't improve it
so by building Sustainable Solutions for
our customers knowing that there is a
direct linkage between our use of
Technology as part of our business
Futures but doing that sustainable way
is the real key for us all right Matt
we've got to leave it there appreciate
you joining me today thank you
well a reminder to you to check out the
Ian King live podcast which you can find
by scanning the QR code that's on your
screen right now so do scan that if you
want to access our podcast that is
available of course wherever you get
your podcasts from including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcasts and
Spotify
and one of the key issues facing the UK
business landscape is the urgent need
for digital transformation and the
ongoing digital skills crisis it raises
ethical questions around emerging
Technologies such as generative Ai and
the future of various job sectors well
the cloud-based Business Solutions
provide a Salesforce is calling on the
government to tackle this by
establishing a national online digital
skills platform joining me now to talk
about this is the chief executive of
Salesforce in the UK and Ireland Zara
barola Lumi Zara good to see you again
um what would uh this entail this
platform
good to see you too and I'm really
pleased that you're featuring this
because we've um we just announced some
research and it's it's worth talking
about kind of the Readiness that people
feel and the importance of digital
skills and then of course I will talk to
you about our brilliant trailer head
platform and what we're urging the
government to do but I think it's worth
just just taking a step back and and why
is this a crisis so you know I it's been
well documented we've we've done some
research we've talked about the fact
that you know 75 of people we spoke to
and it was a large piece of research
just don't feel ready for the digital
skills that are needed for today and
tomorrow and then you overlay the lens
of AI and that picture becomes more
acute and today we've announced some uh
publicized some research where we're
looking at the impact of you know
emerging Technologies like generative Ai
and the impact on the workforce so you
look at you look at AI one in 10 of us
don't feel equipped already for the AI
skills that we need and you know nearly
all of our our respondents told us that
it was the most important skill to have
in the next five years and yet despite
this and despite how people are feeling
you know we've got to do a better job of
making skills accessible and people are
optimistic so they see the value of
generative AI you know we've just
launched our our Einstein GPT and and
the impact that that has in the
workplace and the work to be done so
people are excited they're not
necessarily threatened or worried that
it's going to replace them and nearly
all of our respondents said that
businesses should be investing 96 of
them said that businesses should be
investing in AI skills so you know
there's lots to lots to go after really
to boost our economy so why the skills
platform well look many companies like
Salesforce nearly all of our peers in
the technology industry you know they
they have their own we have our own kind
of training initiative we have our
wonderful Trailhead platform it's free
online gamified digestible way to learn
and acquire digital skills and we know
that we can take a relatively low
skilled low technical skilled person and
make them job ready within as little as
six months so that's an enormous
achievement and and it's really kind of
flexible and if I think about kind of
the privilege we've had we've impacted
five million people through this uh
Trailhead platform and one in three
people that use it go on to find
employment using their Salesforce skills
so what better way we haven't got much
time um
I just want to ask you about your survey
findings uh you say that most people
um actually welcome generative AI in
their workplace they're not frightened a
majority of them of losing their jobs to
it I was quite amazed to read that yes
so more people are excited than they are
threatened
uh that they'll be replaced and when you
see the impact of how it how it changes
jobs to be done and improves
productivity and efficiency you see the
massive combination of AI and human
together to drive greater productivity
and ease of doing business so for
example in our Salesforce platform
Einstein GPT if we apply it to marketing
our marketing Cloud capability we can
personalize content and generate that
really dynamically and apply that in a
personalized way across multiple
channels that reach customers for for
our customers across mobile web
advertising if we apply it to service we
can really help Service agents respond
real time using real-time data to
generate knowledge-based articles using
the historical data within our sales
platform and give customers a real
accuracy of response so it's really
important that you're starting going
back to this platform this this
government required platform bringing
that that pool together of all of the
companies and what they do especially
you know what we do with Trailhead on a
Consolidated platform a One-Stop shop to
allow people to access and understand
what's out there and really choose the
pathway that will benefit them and fit
with their Lifestyles and incorporate
that lifelong learning okay Zara we're
out of time I'm afraid thanks for
joining me today lovely to see you
thanks for having me
[Music]
time for a look now at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with yesterday's
UK inflation figures the ft is currently
leading its Digital Editions meanwhile
with a report that Google plans to
introduce generative artificial
intelligence into its advertising
business over the coming months
potentially helping it produce far more
sophisticated campaigns resembling those
created by marketing agencies the times
leads its business pages with news that
a shareholder Revolt to remove Holger
Lund as chairman of BP's Gathering
momentum it says five of the UK's
biggest pension schemes plan to vote
against his re-election in protest at
the company's watering down of green
commitments meanwhile the times also
reports on its business front page that
Jaguar Land Rover is to drop the 75 year
old Landover brand in a reboot that will
also include a relaunch of Jaguar as an
electric mark
meanwhile The Daily Telegraph well that
also leads with inflation it reports on
the comments uh I was discussing with
Simon French earlier from the office for
National statistics yesterday that
International food prices have started
falling but the supermarkets have not
yet passed these on the telegraph also
uh quotes comments from Michael O'Leary
I say this is getting a lot of pick up
on social media right now I can tell you
Michael O'Leary the chief executive of
Ryanair he predicted yesterday that the
UK is going to rejoin the EU single
Market by a generation and he says that
will be because a generation of European
pro-europeans will exert pressure to do
that while brexit supporters will die
out a lot of people getting quite hot
under the collar about those comments I
can't think why joining me today is toro
Barker he saw Street journal's editor
for Europe the Middle East and Africa
Toro good to see you this morning
um Tesla obviously uh the big
announcement overnight papers giving it
big licks today yeah so
um they've been cutting prices for a
while at Tesla I think last year down 15
to 25 five percent depending on the
model
um but actually their revenue is still
growing very very strongly because
that's really juicing volumes in general
the US market is heading towards
electric the percentage of electric cars
in the fleet is going up quite rapidly
but also they have been quite aggressive
on price at the same time so profits
down quite significantly but uh but
Revenue continuing to grow fast is there
a danger that he damages his brand by
doing this that he makes Tesla a more
commodified product uh that's clearly a
danger I think the reality though is if
you want to be a scale manufacturer
factor in the Auto industry you need to
do that everybody else is catching up
fast they're launching lots of new
models and he still has a much higher
margin structure than the other so even
though margins came down very
significantly this quarter to about 11
just over 11 I think if you look at GM
and Ford they're operating on much lower
margins between four and seven percent
so he's still got room to squeeze them
and generate volume and I and I'm sure
and again and I'm not speaking for Elon
strategy but I'm sure there's there's
plenty of opportunities within that
scale to differentiate between models as
well now in your paper The Wall Street
Journal there's a big read today on lvmh
under succession I mean this is a
fascinating story it is fascinating lvmh
as as people May known as is this
massive company it's about half a
trillion dollars and you know in luxury
has become this beer month and um so
really it's a great read it's worth it's
worth having a look at
um about uh Bernardino's four children
his sort of focus on education on
mathematics on steeping them in the
business and giving them different areas
of the business to run and how he's
planning to sort of choose over time who
who comes out top of that so yeah a
fascinating Empire where again there's
four kids uh looking potentially to take
over at some point here France's biggest
company by country Mark he's also now
we're talking about Elon Musk he's now
the richest man in the world yeah
um or richest person in the world so
yeah about 25 years ago Bernie I've got
to say he's one of the most charismatic
business people I've ever met and
they're really you know people think of
France as being quite a sort of
corporatist country he's a capitalist
read in tooth and Claw no he's he's
built this extraordinary business from
you know he took over the family
business again this article gets into it
um I forget the date of it that took
over and made an acquisition early on
and buried within it was Christian Dior
so you know he then built it off the
back of this a really interesting story
of building this thing through
Acquisitions and aggressive and smart
business practices over many many years
yeah good piece now uh we're in the
middle of the banking update system uh
JP Morgan's caught URI yeah so
um uh no actually Morgan Stanley last
night actually JP Morgan was was earlier
in the week so um uh what you've seen is
this sort of Tale of Two uh banking
models really which is the investment
banking and the trading businesses have
had a really tough time as we know you
know the um the markets have been pretty
challenging you've talked about this a
lot deal making off after this surge in
2021 has come off aggressively so Morgan
Stanley and Goldman Sachs obviously get
hit pretty hard by that and you've seen
that in the earnings and obviously
Goldman laid off six percent of its
Workforce
um at the same time you know something
like JP Morgan which has a big uh
regular Commercial Bank and a retail
bank have done pretty well so they had
record earnings because the net interest
margin which people will know means that
you can as a big Bank keep your deposit
rates low but charge more for loans so
the spread between those two things
increases as interest rates go up so
they've actually had a great year on
that net interest margin but obviously
if you're Morgan Stanley or Goblin Sachs
yeah you don't have that yeah absolutely
that's all good to see you thank you
very much
still to come here on Ian King live the
role of regulators under the spotlight
I'll be joined by the chair of the
regulatory Reform Group of conservative
MPS stay tuned
[Music]
foreign
and we're going to interrupt that to
take you live to yes of course it has a
bearing on what's happening with
interest rates we're cutting out of that
to bring you some breaking news could
you tell us about the night that the
Russians were coming Russia is making
advances now listen it's quite a Time
hasn't it Alex tell us what's happening
this is turning into a humanitarian
emergency
news never stops Nelson breaking news
for you neither do we let's just come
into us here at Sky News
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Global insight made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now the recent rescues of
Silicon Valley bank and credit Swiss
have again shown the spotlight on the
role of regulators us has off gems
oversighted the energy sector amid the
recent outcry over the enforced
installation of prepay meters well the
regulatory Reform Group of conservative
benchers argues in a report published
this week that there's insufficient
parliamentary oversight of regulators
given their power and inference over
Britain's economy would you want to mean
now is the conservative MP4 engine and
hobberton and chair of that group Bim
file Army Bim good to see you this
morning pleasure now you're arguing that
these Regulators are holding back and
hindering economic growth that's quite a
claim well what we're talking about is
the whole regulatory system it's
important to say that there are a lot of
very good regulators and in some
respects the best respected Regulators
in the world but the key is the system
is not always getting the outcomes that
we want so what does that mean it means
clearer lines of accountability between
what the government and politicians are
responsible for and what Regulators are
responsible for clearer understanding of
when decisions have been taken why
they've been taken and that's why the
question of scrutiny is so important
because not just parliamentary more
parliamentary scrutiny which that
scrutiny role used to be was used to be
done in Brussels by the European Union
obviously we've left the European union
now but we haven't really replaced that
with anything so we need parliamentary
scrutiny about the decisions that are
being taken and why
and then also another one of our
recommendations is within government
there needs to be a much more active use
of a team within government we're
calling them the oversight you know the
oversight body of regulators that needs
to work with departments strategically
to look at different areas of Regulation
make sure there's no overlapping
problems identify where there are issues
make sure that the what the government
and Parliament want to be
the decisions that they want happening
are actually being taken in the right
way and so putting these two things
together we hope can provide better
outcomes because better outcomes on
regulation means better industry more
economic growth it's growth yeah I mean
on the point of growth I mean the
financial conduct Authority the
government has already said it wants it
to make the UK's Financial Services set
to more competitive that's part of its
mandate now the industry itself has
pushed back on that
well part of one of the the
we did a lot of work speaking to lots of
people in different Industries not just
Financial Services it's worth saying you
mentioned energy other areas of our of
the regulated economy
thing is that often the intentions the
good intentions of government Parliament
and The Regulators themselves somehow
are not finding their way through on the
ground on how they're implemented that's
why we need to do this work it's not to
say oh this regulator's good or that
regulator's bad it's to say how can we
hold you more accountable for the
decisions that are being taken and that
through that transparency and
accountability we will get better
rulemaking and then more economic growth
at the same time it's the quality of
regulators themselves high enough in
this country I mean a lot of them are
not paid an awful I mean if you look at
the FCA for example I shouldn't just
keep going about financial services but
it's had a real stream of people that
have just left and gone into jobs in the
city in the private sector yeah so one
of the things in our report is to talk
about the culture within the regulators
and to help each of them retain and grow
and develop more high quality people one
way in which we can do that is having
better relationships between industry
and Regulators so that that relationship
can be better informed on the regulatory
side and on the industry side making
sure they have a better understanding
about what the regulator is trying to
achieve and through that on top of
transparency on top of more clear
accountability we think we can get a
better system better relations between
industry and regulator a lot of people
will say oh that's Max of regulatory
capture it doesn't for this precise
reason better better relationship does
not mean that industry will like the
decisions every decision of a regulator
and what somebody very senior in Downey
she said to me the other day was well
Bim if Industries complaining and
government's complaining and The
Regulators complaining maybe the grit in
the system is often working if
everybody's a little bit unhappy and I
can appreciate that best relationship
does however mean that regulatory
Independence which is a core principle
in our system and one that we should
maintain does not mean regulatory
immunity and we've got to make sure that
if stakeholders in the industry feel
that they've been hard done by there are
appropriate mechanisms for them to raise
that in a way that doesn't damage their
relationship with the regulator and
frankly on speaking to Regulators they
would welcome better relationships as
well all right we've only got about 30
seconds left Bim give me give me Excuse
me tell me tell me uh which regulator is
doing a good job in your view right now
where there's not a problem well sorry
there are there are good people in all
Regulators doing doing good jobs I think
one person I would highlight I think the
pra and I think the role that Sam Woods
for example played on the Silicon Valley
Bank transaction with HSBC and for of
once of that I used to work at hsvc um
but for the uh the role he played there
everybody says he did a fantastic job
very good great to see you this morning
thank you thank you that's it from me
I'm back at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
hope very much to see you then in the
meantime coming up after this short
break it's Jane second don't go away
thanks for joining me today cheerio
[Music]